I'm about to show you the fastest,
easiest, and most economical way to make
a spare key for a Honda or Acura View. I
apologize for any wind noise in the
audio today. Hopefully, you can still
hear me well. Before I jump in the car
and show you how easy it is to program
this key, I'm going to start this phone
call to the Honda dealership to find out
what they're going to charge and how
long they would take to make a spare
key. With the call underway, let's jump
in and start programming this spare key.
At tomsky.com, you can order spare keys,
programming device, and be sure you
include our optional key by photo
service. More on that later. As you
begin programming, it's important to
know you must have one working key that
starts the engine. This one with the
tile keyfinder, so I can always find my
keys. Fires the engine up. The remote
buttons on this key still work. But even
if they don't, as long as you have a key
that starts the engine, you can use
Tom's Key Company do-it-yourself
solutions to help make a spare key for
your vehicle. All right, to start out,
we got to scan the QR code. With the app
installed, we're ready to begin
programming. Your spare key will need to
be cut to fit your vehicle. I recommend
using our key by photo key cutting
service. It'll save you a bunch of time
and hassle by having your Q drive
already cut to fit your vehicle. So,
we're gonna pair key. We need to find
the OBD port and plug in this
programming device. On most vehicles,
it's down near the gas and brake pedal.
Sometimes it can be behind a little
cover here. This cord, it's right
there. That thing plugged in. To make
your life a little easier, you can grab
this optional extension cable to see
what's going on with the programmer.
Now I can see that my programmer has
power. We've got to get the Bluetooth
communication working. All right, we
need to find the device. There's a
matching serial number here. May need to
press to scan. Let's see if we can get
our Bluetooth connection
made. And there we go. We saw the com
light turn on. We're ready to
continue. Okay. It's helpful to know
that there is technical support
available Monday through Friday daytime
business hours. So that can be really
helpful if you run into problems. Let's
begin
programming. Okay, calibrating the tool.
We need to enter license plate for scan
the VIN. This isn't 100% foolproof, but
let's go give it a shot. I'm going to go
try the license
plate. Enter license plate. Here we go.
2017 Honda Accord. That is correct for
this vehicle. All right. This is a
turnkey
ignition. So, we'll do the key version.
Smart key is a push button start
ignition. All right, some important
points. Might take up to 15 minutes, but
no longer than that. Don't leave the app
during programming. And be sure you've
got all existing keys previously
programmed, like this one, as well as
any new ones that are going to be
made. Okay, let's begin programming.
While this is initiating, let me tell
you a couple important things. While you
do this, I recommend you turn off the
HVAC, heating, cooling, roll down the
windows if it's hot day, turn off the
headlights, the radio, anything that's
drawing battery from the vehicle because
you don't want your vehicle battery to
run out during the programming process.
You could even connect a trickle charger
to your battery if you're concerned it
might be weak. Let's see how that phone
call with car dealership's
gone. Still a lot of
old. While we're waiting, let me tell
you about our key by photo key cutting
service. This is pretty amazing stuff.
When you place your order, you can add
our optional key by photo key cutting
service. You're going to snap a few
photos of your key, move it around to
get different angles with the phone
directly above the key, sitting on a
flat surface like a table. You want us
to be able to see with the photo the
proper cuts to make. Then using our
keyby key cutting technology, we'll cut
your new key to fit your vehicle. It's
pretty amazing. It'll arrive already
fitting. Okay, we're almost done here.
Getting ready. Please
wait. All right. Turn the ignition two
clicks forward to the on position. Don't
start the engine using your currently
programmed key. Okay, let's
continue. Make sure the ignition is in
the on position with the engine off with
the currently programmed key before
clicking continue. Yes, that is correct.
Engine's not running. I do see some
lights on the dashboard.
Continue. Please wait.
Turn the ignition off. Do not remove the
key. Okay. One two. Ignition is off.
Please wait. If you run into a little
problem, you can contact techport. You
might try starting
over. Please wait. Turn the ignition on
again using the same
key. There you go. One.
Two. Reading the key. Please wait.
Turn the ignition off. Do not remove the
key. One, two. Remove the key from the
ignition less than 15 seconds. Insert
new key and turn two clicks to the on
position. Okay, here's a new one.
Putting it in. One,
two. I look on the dash. I notice a
green security light blinking. That's a
good sign. Part of programming process.
Turn the ignition off. Do not remove the
key. One. Two. Security light is still
blinking. Turn the ignition on again
with the same key. One,
two. Turn the ignition off. Security
light continues to
blink. Turn the ignition on again. Same
key. One, two. I've noticed now that the
security light has turned off. Okay. Is
the security light flashing or on at
this time? No, the security light has
turned off. No, it is turned off. Turn
the ignition off. Do not remove the
key. One,
two. Turn the ignition off again with
the same
key. Okay, please wait. Success.
Awesome. Programming successful. Before
I test this out, let's see how the phone
call with the car dealership's going.
Hi. I'm trying to find out what it costs
to get a uh another key for 2017
Accord. Yep. 137. 137. Awesome. And uh
do you guys have to Are there charges to
cut or program it? Yeah. Program is 190.
190. How long is that going to take?
Okay.
Awesome. I'm trying to find out how long
it would take to get a spare key for my
board.
Okay. Give me one. Okay. Thank you.
Hi, I'm trying to find out what it's
going to cost to get another key made
for a Honda core.
[Music]
Um, and how long does that take?
One full service day. A full service
day. So, like I got to drop the car off.
It's not like bring it in. Just spend a
little bit of time there.
you would drop it off and then you'd be
able to get it back.
Do you know if there's any faster or
cheaper ways like I might any church out
there to get a park team made?
All right. Uh thank you so much for the
info. Can you believe that?
$330 and drop the car off for the entire
day at the dealership. Why would anyone
want to do that when you can come to
toms.com, order your key, we'll cut it
with our key by photo, send you the
programming device, and in about 10
minutes, you'll have a spare and save a
bundle of money. Come to tomskey.com and
place your order today. Programming
successful. Let's hit complete. Systems
restarting. We need to test our new
key. Let's try that out.
I'm going to disconnect the programming
device. Here we go. Let's test out our
new
key. Crank the engine. There we go.
Engine fires right up. Isn't that
awesome? Now, I do want to make sure my
original keys still
work. There we go. Engine started up
nicely. Let's check the lock and unlock
buttons now. Here's the original
key. It works great. Here's the new
one. It works. Look at
that. The new one works as
well.
Excellent. And the trunk works, too. Can
you believe how easy that was? We've now
got two keys for this 2017 Honda Accord.
If you run into problems, no worries.
There's a phone number you can call
during business hours to get support.
You can also visit help.tomskey.com to
find solutions to lots of common
questions. Somehow we still can't get
your spare key working. No worries,
we've got a full money back guarantee.
Ship everything back. You'll get up all
refund. It's that easy. Come visit
tomskey.com. Place your order for spare
key and programming device. Be sure you
include our optional key by photo key
cutting service. Oh, and one more thing.
Would you do me a favor? I'm trying to
reach 10,000 subscribers by the end of
this year. Would you hit that subscribe
button if you found this helpful? Also,
you might want to like the video so you
can find it to follow along when your
programming device and spare key
arrives. Have a great day.